there's never quite been a movie like
Avengers endgame that's probably because
there's never been a movie franchise
like the Marvel Cinematic Universe with
over 20 interconnected movies released
over the span of a decade endgame had
ample opportunities to make tons of
references and callbacks to a sprawling
continuity of characters and plot twists
and while many significant lines of
dialogue were pretty easy to spot like
and I am Iron Man
there were still plenty of other
fantastic callbacks that may have flown
over your head here are some of the
small details you might have missed in
avengers endgame
beware gigantic world ending spoilers
ahead throughout the film we got lots of
direct references to previous movies but
some are less obvious than others for
example when Natasha Romanov and Clint
Barton fly their spaceship to vermeer to
retrieve the soul stone one of them
quipped to the other were a long way
from Budapest that refers back to a
mysterious mission the two of them went
on in their shared past that they
referred to during the events of the
first Avengers film meanwhile just
before the undusted heroes all joined
cap to fight Thanos and his army toward
the end of the film we hear Falcon jump
on the radio to tell his partner on your
left
that's a callback to an cap cap lapping
Falcon when the two first met as
competing joggers at the beginning of
Captain America the Winter Soldier
[Music]
but the most endearing and heartbreaking
callback when happy hogan chats with
morgan after her dad's funeral and asks
if she's hungry she says she wants
cheeseburgers and happy smiles saying
your dad liked cheeseburgers too that's
a reference back to a scene early on in
the very first MCU movie when happy and
pepper pick up Tony after his rescue
from the ten rings and he demands two
things that pepper call a press
conference and an American cheese burger
like father like daughter
unless you spent a lot of time watching
youtube videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe there's a better than
decent chance that you have no idea what
Avengers endgame directors Joe and
Anthony Russo look like well you
actually got a great look at one half of
the directing duo you just might not
have realized it at the time when the
movie jumps five years forward in time
we catch up with Steve Rogers and his
support group in Queens New York in that
circle of trust is a man who says he in
a date spent the whole evening talking
and crying that guy is Joe Russo the
younger half of the directors who also
helmed three other epic MCU entries
Captain America the Winter Soldier
Captain America Civil War and Avengers
infinity war this also wasn't Joe
Russo's first time in front of the
camera either he appeared in an episode
of Arrested Development a show for which
he and Anthony directed several episodes
as well as in their film you me and
Dupree in all three of their other MCU
films though Joe's part is birth the
paparazzi in infinity war hit the
cutting room floor before the movie made
it to theaters meanwhile in addition to
directing episodes of Arrested
Development the Russo's also got behind
the lens for several episodes of Dan
Harmon's beloved sitcom community and
that's why two familiar faces from that
show Ken Zhang and Yvette Nicole Brown
who played senior Ben Chang and Shirley
Bennett respectively appear over the
running time of endgame John shows up
early working the security desk at the
storage place containing
van while Brown appears about halfway
through the movie during the jaunt to
the shield base in the 1970s as the
camera pans past Hank pins workbench at
the shield base in the 70s a distinct
looking helmet sitting amid the rest of
his stuff stood out long time comic book
fans recognized it immediately as the
original Helmut Pym used in the comic
books to chat with his ant buddies
curious about how the helmet works
lucky you back in tales to astonish
number 35 where the helmet first
appeared
we got a handy-dandy diagram explaining
all of the helmets inner workings while
it stands to reason that a real helmet
made for talking to ants would need
something a lot more sophisticated than
miniaturized electronic equipment it was
still extremely cool to see this
important piece of Marvel Comics lore
show up on the big screen Clint Barton's
return to the Avengers gave many fans
what they've wanted ever since infinity
war but endgame also delivered a slyly
concealed reference to the comic book
pages that only the most ardent Marvel
fans may have noticed when Scott Lang is
freaking out over doing the time-travel
test with the last remaining Pym
particles barton quickly volunteers to
take his place the moment makes a lot of
sense for his character as he's got
nothing left to lose by this point and
he's ready to do whatever it takes to
try and satisfy the Avengers mission to
restore the world however if you
followed Barton's comic book exploits
over the years you'll know that he has a
tendency to reach for the Pym particles
when he wants to change things up in
Avengers number 63 Barton got fed up
with not being able to contribute as
much as his superpower teammate so he
dropped the Hawkeye stick drank some Pym
particles in took the name Goliath
instead of relying on his superior
marksmanship and fighting abilities
Barton well Barton got big and smash
stuff in a movie as gigantic as Avengers
end game it'd be truly impossible to
catalog every single character's
appearance let alone even recognize a
fair number of them in the first place
case in point only the most dedicated of
Marvel fans may have recognized Howard
Starks Butler from Steve and Tony's
visit to 1970 but loyal viewers of the
late lamented agent Carter TV series
from 2015 to 2016 would have
recognized Edwin Jarvis played by James
D'Arcy both on the small screen and an
end game the movies writing duo of
Christopher Markus and Stephen McFeely
were executive producers on the show so
they probably had a plan to bring their
beloved Butler back with this giant MCU
swan song for quite a while meanwhile in
a truly blinking you'll miss it moment
none other than Howard the Duck joined
all the heroes during the big battle
with Thanos and his army keep your eyes
trained at the bottom right of the
screen when all of the resurrected
heroes step through dr. Strange's
portals in the third act specifically
when hope Van Dyne and the Ravagers
appear if you pay attention you'll catch
little Howard running onto the
battlefield with a gun in his hands
believe it or not this is the third
appearance Howard is made in the MCU he
first showed up in the post-credits
scenes for guardians of the galaxy and
then appeared again on the party planet
of contracts eeeh and guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 shouting up a nice lady
the phrase end game appeared twice in
previous Avengers films the first time
came when Tony Stark was defending his
reasons for building Ultron with
Avengers we can bust arms dealers all
the live long day but that up there
that's that's the end game then an
infinity war Doctor Strange gave Thanos
the time stone a move that no one could
believe when stark asked him why strange
echoed his earlier Ultron explanation
we're now endgame meanwhile is a phrase
that's commonly used in chess to signify
that the game is winding down because
there aren't very many pieces left on
the board a pretty accurate summation
when it comes to the status of the
Earth's heroes by the time the film
starts up however it might not surprise
you to know that way way back in 1969
the 71st issue of the Avengers comic
book had a story called endgame the two
don't have a ton in common on the
surface the comic book version features
characters like the Black Knight and
Kang the Conqueror two guys who have yet
to appear in the MCU in any form but the
stories also have more similarities than
you might expect
in the comic book The Avengers fight
their way through time sometimes
battling once and future members to save
the planet
is it worth rereading some random comic
book from the late 1960s to get some
better insight on one of the most
successful blockbuster movies of the
last ten years probably not but the
similarities do seem at least a little
too close for the name to be a total
coincidence check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about Avengers endgame are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]